a young couple should we who tied the
knot um as um young reservists um
it was when russia began to invade their
homeland of ukraine since then both have
joined the territorial defense forces to
help repel the russian army yariana as
that is
uh joining us uh now hello to you both
thank you for joining us on the program
it's about a month or so i think since
you uh were married um tell us how the
last month has been for you both
whichever of you wants to answer first
this was the
most strange and hard honeymoon we could
ever have
uh from the second day of our marriage
and ukrainian war
we have been to the treacheral defense
of kiev
and uh on that day at night my husband
has lived for his uh first combat
mission and i see that night as the
hardest of my life
we have been at the territorial defense
for one month the hardest months for
kieva when the russian army uh has tried
to invade the kiev region and uh there
were huge fights near host
and right now we see the terrific photos
and videos from that places like
uh and uh
that is like the thing why we joined the
churchill defense the russia has been
enemy for ukraine for
years for hundreds of years they have
been starving people in 1932 1933
they have been killed repressed they
have sent them to prisons for no reason
uh that is the real
evil we wanted to fight for
and uh that is why we have joined the
territorial defense
as fascist love what is the um what's
the mood like uh within the ukrainian
defense team at the moment
well
totally almost uh part of war and
also was the
uh commute of authority that is really
um
we were really very uh
we were really very brave very joyful we
just laughing at russians we just uh
we just hate them and
begin and uh beginning to
uh
to a joyful of them to
uh
to offer to offer them because
we
uh really understand that we
[Music]
every one of us is on our uh is on our
ground is uh on
in our place in our country and
we don't want to
uh
give our country to them we don't want
to have no choice like them
because
we understand that many russians
come here not because they want to come
here and just because
someone sent them here and they don't
have any ability and don't have
a right to
say
that to say something like they don't
want to come here and many of them now
killing
my people killing
many civilians many ukrainian civilians
because
first of all because they
as i can see the news here they like it
and that's the most terrific things
about that that is the thing why uh i
don't think as my husband has told that
they didn't want to come to ukraine like
you know in 2014 when we had very huge
struggles with russians and facebook
because of crimea because of the eastern
ukraine a lot of people were just uh
writing like we will come to our your
land and we will kill and rape and right
now they are doing this
uh i remember i have seen in this news
uh yesterday a terrific story of a woman
uh near har ki were in harkev uh who had
to stay with her ill mother her mother
couldn't move so she didn't have an
ability to
go away and three russian soldiers have
came and one of them has stayed and had
was raping her for one week and then he
maybe uh fell in love i understand how
to talk about that but he just asked her
to leave the country with him and she
refused saying that she has to stay with
her uh ill mother then he took a gun and
she shooted her mother in front of her
and that is why they are not humans
anymore they are
worse than animals and uh not only
laughing at them and jokes about them
right now the strongest thing which
moves all ukrainians volunteering
fighting and doing everything to bring
the victory closer to us is hate
real hate for those who were raped who
were killed for all those children women
for all those ill and old people it's
like not the thing that should happen in
the 21st century
okay guys um i cannot even begin to
imagine um the the challenging start to
your married life hopefully there will
be more peaceful times ahead and before
too long thank you very much indeed for
joining us on the programme please
keep safe in kiev thank you
thank you
thank you